the damage caused by one of several air
strikes in the northwest province of
Italy survivors tried to salvage what's
left
[Music]
emergency crews combed the rubble to
recover the body of a child other
civilians were among the casualties in
adlib city in the afternoon it Lib city
was targeted by Sukhoi 23 Jets they hit
the industrial area and al Holl market
most of those hurt have serious injuries
in a nearby hospital France console a
father
grieving his son a ceasefire which
started on Sunday was shattered on
Wednesday
when Syrian and Russian jets attack it
that City as well as several rebel-held
towns the ceasefire was brokered by
Turkey which supports the rebels and
Russia which backs the Syrian
government's nine-month offensive
fighters linked to al-qaeda are the
strongest forces in these areas home to
around 3 million civilians according to
the UN close to 400,000 Syrians have
been forced from their homes in Italy in
the past 10 weeks the Kremlin says it's
targeted rebels who've attacked civilian
government health areas and what's
supposed to be a so-called de-escalation
zone Russia and Turkey are reported to
have been negotiating the establishment
of a secure zone for the displaced
during the winter and Russia has
announced humanitarian corridors have
already been established to allow people
in it Lib to cross over into
government-held territory it's unclear
how many have chosen to go
katia lupus of a yawn al Jazeera now the
Turkish humanitarian organization IHH is
based in Italy and it says in the past
two and a half months nearly 400,000
Syrians have been forced from their
homes including a quarter of a million
children and 100 children are among 311
civilians killed many survivors are in
during the winter in makeshift tents
with poor hygiene and that Turkish
organization accuses the Syrian
government and its Russian allies of
bombing markets mosques schools health
centers and water treatment plants while
Sarika Ali is the Sira researcher at
Human Rights Watch and she joins us now
on skype from Amman in Jordan Sarah
let's start with the situation on the
ground in Libya at the moment the
ceasefire is effectively over so how
many people are now left caught up in
the fighting they're currently in Italy
we have over 4 million people the larger
portion of them civilians who are
essentially trapped in the inn in
Northwest Syria and Idlib Governorate
between the Turkish blocked border and
relentless bombardment from the Syrian
Russian military alliance all of their
lives right
our artists Sara I also am curious
because we've seen these huge population
movements since this latest offensive
began people moving towards the Turkish
border how are people coping with winter
conditions there I mean the humanitarian
situation that live is really dire since
December first you have 350,000 people
who move north as a result of the Syrian
arson military offensive and although
humanitarian organizations are scaling
up their operations they simply can't
keep up with the demands so you have
families that are out in the open in the
middle of freezing freezing weather no
tents no shelter no food people are
starving to death and this governor if
they're not being bombed they're dying
because they're hungry so I remember the
amount of an access to cross-border aid
in that region was slashed in order to
get that resolution through the Security
Council so what's been the impact on the
ground as a result of that in terms of
the good thing is that the two border
crossings where aid is coming in to live
has been have survived even though
they've only survived for six months so
we don't know what's going to be
happening in six months but we do know
that that I don't think we're there
crossing in the Autopia which goes to
Northeast Syria has been slashed
resulting in decreased humanitarian aid
to up to around 1 million and a half
people who are in Northeast Syria the
the slashing of this resolution
essentially is a clear signal to the
international community that in six
months the same crisis could be
exacerbated in Enderlin sorry there's
already a UN investigation going on into
where the war crimes have been committed
in at liban and broadly in Syria
throughout the war these latest
airstrikes that we've been talking about
hit and market in your opinion are war
crimes ongoing then in Human Rights
Watch's assessment yes it's likely that
many of these attacks on protected
civilian and destruction infrastructure
where there is large civilian presence
and no real military targets are likely
to be war crimes we've documented these
attacks on displacements
on schools and hospitals and it seems
that the pattern has not has not stopped
sorry you've been covering this for some
time and it's been years and years of
war now where do we go from here for the
people of ed Lib I think this is this is
the question that needs to be asked we
have four million people who are relying
on us to do something to protect them
we've raised this countless times the
Syrian Arsenal military alliance has not
paid heed turkey has not opened its
border to people fleeing the violence
this is it this is the moment of truth
and unless something changes drastically
on the ground it's likely that we're
going to be seeing this tragedy unfold
before our very eyes and we will be held
responsible for the deaths of millions
of civilians Sarah kai Ali there the Sri
Racha Human Rights Watch thank you for
joining us on al jazeera SAR thank you